oggi maestro Favij di cucina la bistecca
ma non una bistecca qualsiasi prestata
attenzione bistecca bicondita si prende
una bistecca e la si taglia a metà la
bistecca la si mette qua la seconda
parte invece la si Puccia solo prendiamo
di nuovo la prima parte la giriamo dalla
parte opposta perché no una volta che la
bistecca è cotta Perfetto La togliamo
mettiamo la bistecca all'interno del
piatto Noi siamo pronti a tutto Ecco qua
No vabbè Eh tanto c'è la regola di 5
secondi Ecco qua perfetto si prende il
piatto e metto
Si posizionano le due bistecche in
questa maniera qua melanzane Perfetto Ok
L'ultimo passaggio per il nostro
capolavoro culinario un po' di birra
giustamente una volta versato il della
birra nel piatto
una volta aromatizzato il nostro cibo te
lo prendiamo e lo portiamo pronto per
essere servito
per altre ricette seguite